Ну що, поїхали! Що таке клітор? Де він розташований? І чи важливий він узагалі?
Багато хто думає, що клітор виглядає так. Маленька намистинка з плоті.
Знаходиться десь "там внизу". І чекає, як би розважитися. І роль клітора взагалі неважлива.
Що ж, це сумно. Адже це - неправда!
Клітор може збільшуватися в три рази в збудженому стані!
Це Лайя Вальс Перес. Вона гінекологиня. І розповість нам усю правду про клітор.
Давайте розглянемо детальніше. Фактично, це все, що ви дізнаєтеся з більшості книг.
У деяких виданнях клітор взагалі не згадується!
Інші вказують тільки на невеликий шматочок плоті. От і все.
НІ! Це не правильно! Вони не беруть до уваги інше - по суті, найважливіше!
Так, "зовні" клітор виглядає так. Просто невелика горошина. Гаразд. Але зачекайте! Адже це - наче верхівка айсберга!
Більша частина клітора перебуває під шкірою!
Насправді клітор досить великий. Близько 10 сантиметрів!
Так що це - лише та частина, яку ви бачите зовні. Але ще у клітора є дві ніжки і дві цибулини.
Погляньте знову - це вам щось нагадує?
Клітор не тільки схожий на пеніс. У клітора і пеніса багато спільного!
І клітор, і пеніс наливаються кров'ю і збуджуються, якщо їх стимулювати.
Тож, так: у всіх у нас "стоїть"! І ми всі виділяємо рідини під час оргазму!
Різниця в тому, що ми просто знаємо набагато більше про пеніс і сперму, ніж про клітор і вагінальний еякулят!
З глузду з'їхати, чи не так ?!
Пеніс і клітор так схожі! У них деякі частини - однакові, і дуже схожа структура.
І вони мають однакове походження - розвиваються з одних і тих же тканин ембріона.
Так що твердження "Чоловіки - протилежність жінкам" - насправді не правильне!
До речі, клітор може стати майже таким же великим, як пеніс!
У стані збудження клітор може збільшитися в три рази! Це найерогенніша зона в людському тілі.
Клітор містить близько 8000 нервових закінчень. Неймовірно! Це вдвічі більше, ніж у пеніса!
І жінки також еякулюють під час оргазму!
Отже, якщо ви коли-небудь задавалися питанням, що це за рідина з'являється під час оргазму - ні, це не сеча! Це жіночий еякулят!
То для чого ж нам потрібен клітор? Просто для задоволення? Ну, насамперед - так! Для особливого задоволення...
Клітор - це жіночий орган для отримання сексуального задоволення. Ви можете стимулювати його зовні, у вульві. Або зсередини, в піхві.
Так що не буває вагінального оргазму! Піхва не настільки чутлива - інакше жінка не змогла б народжувати, було б надто боляче.
У кожному оргазмі задіяний клітор. І це має вирішальне значення.
А як щодо точки "Джі"? Те саме, загадкове місце! Нібито найважливіше місце в жіночому оргазмі?
Точка "джі"? Що ж, це міф. Її не існує. Це внутрішня частина клітора, тому що його ніжки лежать навколо піхви!
Отже, підсумуємо: так, клітор приносить сексуальне задоволення! Але це задоволення не просто прекрасне відчуття ...
Близько 400 років тому люди дійсно думали, що жінка може завагітніти, тільки якщо вона і її коханець отримають оргазм - разом!
Тепер ми знаємо: в цьому є лише частка правди.
Деякі дослідження стверджують, що ймовірність завагітніти збільшується, якщо жінка відчуває оргазм.
Причина в тому, що вагінальний еякулят допомагає сперматозоїдам просуватися в потрібному напрямку.
Але навіть якщо ви НЕ хочете завагітніти - клітор приносить ще масу іншої користі…
Регулярні оргазми поліпшують ваше здоров'я. Вони корисні для сну, для серця, знімають стрес!
І вони також добре позначаються на стані вашої шкіри. Думаю, ми всі хочемо цього...
Симпатичний орган, клітор, чи не так? І хоча його більшу частину нам не видно, він таїть у собі багато сюрпризів!
Так що зверніть на нього увагу - і цінуйте гідно!